what up everybody by now you've heard
Affleck is going to be Batman in the
Batman vs. Superman movie I think it's
kind of a blah choice but who cares what
I think I wanted to talk to a flex base
so I came down here to talk to Red Sox
fans to see what they think about
Affleck as Batman check it out
Devin what do you think about Boston
native Ben Affleck being cast as Batman
I don't know I'm interested to see what
he can do he's he's done some good stuff
recently it's a lousy decision they got
to change it well that's interesting he
didn't really pull it off in that other
super Sam what was that flick need a
green honor the Sun daredevil dad devil
was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
it was a getting waist how do you feel
about Ben Affleck being named the new
Batman he's hot but he ain't for this
role it's gonna be awful
why I just doesn't have the range he's
not a good actor
Batman's from Gotham Ben Affleck's from
Boston don't make no sense
Gotham is not a real place you know Opie
Axl well the last couple pictures he had
with Warner Brothers makes him fairly a
valuable property to Warner and they
need to do something to make him stay
with the studio this is the first
intelligent answer we've gotten all damn
day do you think he's gonna be a wicked
pissah Batman uh nope he didn't even
have a cool car so you got that out of
me so I let you have that one nice nice
uh where do you pack the car and have it
yeah yeah I got it out of Southie uh
represent for Boston you want something
we don't even say that all wicked or
pisser either put that in down the who
the started that wicked pissah ain't
nothing I ever said let me ask you this
time do you think Ben Affleck could be a
wicked pissah Batman he didn't get it
when I just said it did he how would
Derek Jeter be his Batman well if he
ends up dying I'm good with it I guess
how do you feel about Tom Brady is
Batman sure why not
larry Baer would be an excellent Batman
and I'll tell you why he's got he's got
the height which Batman typically lacks
he can soar you see him jump he's got
he's got ups how do you feel about a
Gerard Butler that'd be better than
Affleck Gosling I would've said yes all
right
probably a good choice Justin Bieber
absolutely [ __ ] not
what about Bieber oh no please too young
to know what does Batman's voice sound
like oh I don't know if I could do
Batman
give us a give us a Batman impression on
Batman that was terrible
we're in Boston do you think the Batcave
should be at the stadium at Fenway Park
yes I want to touch that grass you're
making everything you say sound very
sexual how much we had to drink today
actually just one beer sure I for one
will be boycotting this movie who's with
me
Ike wicked pissah Ben Affleck and Batman
if you really wanna know the truth I
want to know the trick and airplay
that's all I'm doing
who would you like to see as Batman me
well there was some Affleck love and
there was some Affleck hate and there
was some stay the F added Charlestown
and get your ass out of Southie who do
you think should be the new Batman you
let us know in the comments section
below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank you for watching
hit me up on Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick bye
bye boobs
every time so down hello humans my name
is Optimus Prime
everywhere I go I'm walking
previously on AMC's The Walking Dead